ich gehe davon aus dass von den 245 000
betrieben unserer branche ein drittel
den winter nicht überstehen wird und
deswegen muss jetzt gehandelt werden
wenn unsere branche hier eine sonderlast
zu tragen hat gemeinsam mit der
veranstaltungswirtschaft dann muss am
mittwoch auch darüber entschieden werden
wie ein ausgleich eine entschädigung
stattfinden kann ansonsten werden wir
die nächsten wochen nicht überleben und
darüber muss sich die politik im klaren
sein also einen allgemeinen lockt darum
gilt es zu verhindern
wenn man aber eine branche und der
veranstaltungswirtschaft hier ein quasi
berufsverbot auferlegt dann muss auch
klar sein wie diese branchen
unterstützung erfahren dass sind
familienunternehmen kleine wie große
sind alle brutal hart getroffen von
diesem corona ja und da muss mehr
passieren als bislang
jetzt gibt es ja in allen restaurants
und bars bereits hygiene- konzepte damit
man die korona situation besser in griff
bekommt an manchen funktioniert das bei
manchen leider nicht wir sehen uns immer
wieder gibt es denn ein gegenvorschlag
von ihnen von der dehoga wie man das
ganze vielleicht noch besser
kontrollieren könnte ohne alles
schließen zu müssen also bei den meisten
restaurants hotels klappt das wunderbar
sie haben unglaublich viel investiert in
die schutzkonzepte und deswegen sind die
zahlen ja auch dort nicht relevant und
es gibt einzelne fälle wo das nicht
geschehen ist und ihr hätte auch
sicherlich intensiver früher
kontrolliert werden müssen in den
letzten wochen und monaten und sagt man
mit den illegalen partys hat meine
branche nichts zu tun
also wenn hier in berlin jetzt am
wochenende fetisch partys oder sonstwas
stattfinden
das ist nicht meine branche und es wäre
völlig unverhältnismäßig aufgrund dieser
einzelfälle
eine ganze branche zu schlimm mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schau dich je das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren